you've got the best pipes in the
business you're his voice
thank you is so incredible yeah i try to
get voice over work and i'm like
buy this product yeah
yeah that's the response i get well they
also like the ads to be more specific
yeah
i know that's true that was a little bit
that's obviously for granny smith apples
right
i didn't idea granny smith apples are
real good
you know it's uh no i do voiceovers is a
great thing and i and i do a lot and
and i actually to be honest coming here
today i'm kind of behind on a couple of
jobs
i just you know would you mind while i'm
here because you guys are micked up and
stuff if
would you mind if i just did a couple
you want to do some voiceover
that's okay don't worry about it i don't
think it's appropriate i just have lots
of equipment here and i brought my
my setup with me okay there you go i
brought my setup i can't believe i
didn't see that back this is just a
little
just like a little bit closer and i got
my headphones here so you're just like
hands as we call them in the biz
yeah that's a real thing okay so you're
gonna
just do a voiceover or two i'm just
gonna do a couple of things i got we're
rolling here right
you record these and then you just use
them right yeah yeah no no no i mean
it's fine we can totally we're totally
rolling and just stay within three
two plug one headphones innovative
creative and tough as nails that's the
american spirit
and that's the all-new gmc sierra 1500
pickup truck
yeah okay
we're just going to keep rolling here
because we're rolling girls
here we go hey girl i love your smile
crest white strips
yeah that's good hanging them out we're
banging them out
we're done oh we're not done here hang
on just we're still rolling here here we
go
we're in three two one fleniman's racist
butter
spread it all around
wait a minute that couldn't be a product
is that butter for racist people or is
the butter itself racist i don't know
i do not know and i don't care as long
as the check clears okay so let's do
we're gonna do a voice over here for a
film for uh this is cookie the fruit bat
in three
tone are you pulling my wing
okay we got that great and we're gonna
do one here we're still rolling
delete that one please we're gonna do
one he's not gonna need that
yeah i got it we got to do one for
cantonese market too
he know my ring
how am i doing gene i love what i'm
hearing man
keep them coming who the hell who the
hell is that guy
that's uh that's gene that's gene my my
uh the groovy audio engineer that i
bring with me everywhere
what's happening baby why is there a
camera on him yeah
because we live i like i need to know
he's there
okay he wanders away
i like look he does wander away because
you know because we're not he's
you know we're doing it by uh by a isdn
line you don't know what i'm talking
about
here we go here we go i just got one
more i got to do he's fast he's funny
he's the only late night talk show that
matters tune in for last call with
carson daly
what the hell you can't plug other talk
show hosts on this show
man i'm a slave to my copy conan let's
wrap it up
okay this is the last one okay so yeah i
promised
guys that i dub a few danish porno films
in english here in this
you're gonna do danish porno yeah yeah
and it's great that you're here because
i need somebody to play the lady
no no you know what you're gonna be
great you're gonna be great now here's
i'm gonna set up the scene
yeah you're the lady i just delivered
you a six-foot party sub and now i'm
delivering you a footlong if you know
what i'm talking about
oh oh yeah
oh yeah oh that's copenhagen style
oh yeah this is how we do it in denmark
girl
oh no wait one second i don't know if
i'm feeling this kind of flat uh
well you know what i i actually have a
bowl of jello and a plunger i could do
some sound effects that would be great
that would be great all right
but you know what you know what that
reminds me if you might just keep doing
that because i actually got another job
i got to do that keep going
mom's preferred jell-o grandchildren
all right we're getting out of here
we're taking a break